JULIE ANN CROMMETT:
Hey, everyone.
How are you?
Monday-- Monday
lunchtime, are we awake?
Yeah.
Hello.
Idina, thank you so much
for being here and sharing
with us at Google.
We could not be more thrilled.
And as you can see, you
got a huge lunchtime crowd
coming out.
IDINA MENZEL: I'm only
focusing on the empty seats.
Where are those people?
JULIE ANN CROMMETT: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
IDINA MENZEL: My manager hates
me because whenever I play,
I'll play like a
packed house, and I'll
see two people in the front
that just probably their kid got
sick and they couldn't make it.
And I'm like, why didn't
we sell those two fucking
seats in the front?
[LAUGHTER]
He's like, I did!
I swear to God!
I hate it.
It just makes me insecure.
Anyway, sorry, am I
allowed to curse at Google?
JULIE ANN CROMMETT: Yeah.
Yeah, you're good.
This is an adult
audience, so we're good.
[LAUGHTER]
Nobody here has ever
cursed in their whole life.
I can see it now.
So thank you for coming.
You have a new album out
and one that is, I think,
somebody has told me
deeply personal to you.
And would love to lead off
there of your journey and sort
of what led you to this album.
IDINA MENZEL: I think
most people's album's
deeply personal.
Everybody asks me that.
And it is.
It's true.
But I don't know.
It's like whose album do we
love that isn't deeply personal?
JULIE ANN CROMMETT:
Right, one would hope.
IDINA MENZEL: But mine is.
Yeah.
The last three
years, I guess, I had
like a lot of
conflicting dynamics,
I guess you could say.
I was simultaneously
going through a divorce
while "Frozen" was going on
its whole crazy trajectory.
So I literally would go
from singing at the Oscars
to heading to a
mediation agreement,
discussing like
visitation about my son.
So it was just
professionally speaking,
an incredible time, and
personally speaking,
very complicated.
So I had a lot to write about.
And it just felt like a good
time to get back in the studio
and put it into some music.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT:
That's awesome.
Thank you for going there so
early in the conversation.
IDINA MENZEL: Personal.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT:
It was amazing.
And as you were sort of building
the album as well and just
being the theater
geek that I am,
I'm thinking about the time and
place we are in theater right
now, with what's happened with
"Hamilton," what we're seeing
and sort of transformative.
And you've really been a part of
some of the most transformative
shows in theater, period.
Everybody, "Rent," right?
[APPLAUSE]
Right, there's the applause.
Yeah.
Right?
And not to mention
"Wicked," yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
There we go, just
two right there.
IDINA MENZEL: I do one every
10 yeare-- one zeitgeist
kind of project every 10 years.
And the rest I starve,
and I go into obscurity.
And then all of a
sudden, I get a job,
and it's like, oh,
that's a big deal.
And then I'm back on top again.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT:
You basically
just drop the mic constantly.
IDINA MENZEL: I wish I was
cool enough to actually do
a mic drop like that.
But, no, I've been
really, really lucky.
But I also have experienced
the ebb and flow
of this industry,
which I think is
why I am able to really enjoy
it when those moments happen,
because I know how
fleeting they can be.
So I actually, more than
ever, can get on stage
and take in the moment and
realize how lucky I am.
And who knows what's
going to happen tomorrow.
And, wow, people showed up.
But that all started with my
first professional experience,
which was "Rent" and that
entire mindset of our composer
passing away on the
night of our first--
I think it was our
invited dress, which
is like the night
before an audience.
Actually, no, it was
the first preview,
because there was-- no,
invited dress, yeah.
Anyway, so when your career
starts with that kind of event,
it kind of dictates how you
see this industry and your art
and gives you a perspective.
And I was lucky because
we were at a young age
that that happened.
And we could of like lost
perspective and objectivity.
But instead of getting caught
up in all the magazines
and the accolades,
our cast actually--
I've never worked in any
show that this has ever
happened since.
Not one person missed a show
for at least six months--
eight shows a week, singing
at the top of our lungss--
because we were so committed,
whether we were sick or not,
to getting up there and making
sure we put out his message.
That was the most
important thing.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT:
Wow, that's amazing.
And with that-- I hadn't
even thought about that
actually in the context
of that question.
Before that moment, you've
talked about the ebbs
and flows.
And obviously, that
was both, again,
at the same time that sort of
trajectory, which you talked
about actually up top with
your album now as well,
the conflicting
emotions of the high
and the low at the same time,
which is the same thing that
happened with "Rent."
Up to that point,
which is the stuff
we can't really Google is before
"Rent," what was the seed that
got planted in you
wanting to do theater,
wanting to sing all the time?
What was that
driving force for you
that led you to that sort of
first big professional moment
of "Rent" that you feel
prepared you for-- or did it?
IDINA MENZEL: Oh, yeah,
there are different ones.
It's kind of like saying
what your first love was.
Was it the kid in
kindergarten that like
kissed you on the
cheek or was it
the guy you first had sex with?
What's first love,
really, right?
So that's a really bad example.
[LAUGHTER]
JULIE ANN CROMMETT: It's OK.
We're just getting real here.
IDINA MENZEL: No, but I do.
I always think about that.
It's like when people
say first love, well,
I think I really loved
this kid Evan Beller when
I was in kindergarten,
but I certainly
didn't let him go up
my shirt or anything.
Do you know what I mean?
[LAUGHTER]
Is it-- how early--
I think I'm tired.
The album came out
this week, and I've
been like surprising drag shows
and gay clubs at midnight.
And I'm like, I don't know
what time zone I'm on.
So you're going to get
me a little delirious
and stick foot
directly into mouth.
What was the question again?
[LAUGHTER]
Oh, yeah, first,
like moment, right?
Well, yes, so my
point being, it could
either be when my Grandfather
Nathan, Grandpa Nat would
put a fake toy microphone
in my hand when I was five
and do shows with me
in the living room.
Or it could be when I
sang at this talent show.
We're up in the Catskills,
where the Jews all go.
And it was a family
trip, and our parents
sent us to the day camp, and
we did this little talent show.
And I say "The Way We Were" with
a full-on Long Island accent.
But everybody's percolating.
People turned to my parents and
said, oh, she could be special.
So like I don't know.
There's those times.
And that was about
theater, yeah.
Oh, it could have been the
time when my grandmother took
me to see "A Star is Born"
with Barbra Streisand and Kris
Kristofferson.
That kind of changed
my life, that idea
of being put on a stage
and having to win over
an audience of people that were
booing you, and being so good
and captivating, that it stopped
them all in their tracks.
Something about that
was amazing to me.
And then parents got divorced
when I was a teenager.
And my mom was dating this
cool guy that really believed
in me a lot and said,
you should write music,
and knew some guy that was
in the wedding/bar mitzvah
scene in Long Island and
helped me lie about my age,
because I was 15 and illegally
driving to all of these gigs,
and got me a gig with Tony Syeda
and the Echoes in Oceanside.
And I knew like three songs.
It was "What a Feeling" from
"Flashdance," "Evergreen,"
and I forget that song--
like the sunshine song.
[HUMMING]
Anyway, I can't think of it.
But and then I started doing
weddings and bar mitzvahs
and having to learn
all this music.
And it was like an
education for me.
I had to learn like Motown and
Aretha and jazz, Billie Holiday
and Ella Fitzgerald.
And all of a sudden
then, I didn't
want to necessarily do theater.
I wanted to be like a rock star.
So I went back and forth between
"Annie," when I was little,
and "Peter Pan" and then wanting
to write my music and record
and all that.
And so it's been
a constant dance
for me, even till this
day, sitting here with you,
trying to get people
to accept my desire
to cross over from the
theater and have integrity
as a rock or a pop
singer/songwriter.
It's just followed
me, this little dance,
trying to straddle both places
and be accepted in both.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT:
And do you feel
like that's really--
by the way, I'm
just picturing you singing
at bar mitzvahs in my head.
And did you feel like with this
album, and even just looking
at the track list
and people's comments
really picking up on your
pop track in a real way,
the intentionality there
of all the genre crossing
because of your influences, what
was your thought process there?
And what do you hope, as
we all listen to the album,
what we hear from you
as part of that journey?
IDINA MENZEL: Yeah,
thanks for asking that.
Well, it's funny.
I've done a couple
albums before this
that it meant more to me,
this whole crossover thing.
And it didn't happen.
I got dropped, or I sold like
three albums or whatever.
So at this point in my
life, so many things
have happened that I'm proud of.
And I get up on stage
and I do a concert,
and the setlist is a
chronology of my life
of the songs in my life.
And some of it's "Defying
Gravity" from "Wicked."
And some of it's an
old Joni Mitchell song
because it inspired me.
And then there's "Let
It Go" from "Frozen."
And then there's original music.
And I used to worry that that
was confusing in some way
and didn't have the cohesion.
But now I realize the cohesion,
the common denominator,
is me and all of my experiences.
And I'm 45 years old, and
that is this is who I am.
This is the life I've led.
And so I kind of stopped
trying to worry-- I've
got to stop worrying about it.
And so when I went in
the studio this time,
I picked producers that I love
that I have worked with people
that I really admire.
But once we got
in there, we just
wrote music and hung
out and recorded,
and I stopped
worrying about that.
All I cared about was that
they supported me being honest
and trying different things.
But what I think
has happened is it
has a really cool, current,
mainstream kind of sound.
And so hopefully-- I just want
to expand my audience, really.
That's all.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT: I love that.
And it's really
interesting also,
given the context,
interestingly,
of this groundbreaking
theater you've
been a part of that sort of
bent also what is theater
and what the music is
that isn't theater.
I'm thinking about
"Rent" rock and "Wicked"
really taking us into like
full Broadway big belt number,
and thinking even about the
trajectory of theater itself
right now, with "Hamilton" and a
lot of experimenting happening,
and also with the
advent of digital.
We're here at Google and
thinking about all the artists
that are sort of genre
crossing, because there's
no box you have to live in.
IDINA MENZEL: Exactly, and we
have more control as artists.
We can put ourselves
in self promote.
We don't have to rely just on
our label understanding us.
We can trust the public to just
want to hear music, love music.
And like so many of the
theater fans I have,
there are amazing
music aficionados.
They love music.
They're not just theater kids.
They love everything.
They just love good
music and good writing.
So why not just put it out there
and let the people find it?
So that's really
empowering for artists now.
Back in the day, when I was
trying to get a record deal
and playing down at the
Bitter End in the Village,
it was all about just getting
a record deal and the label
and being accepted
by these people.
And now, as long
as you can tour,
which is the most
important thing to me,
to be able to make a
paycheck and go out and sing
and on a stage for people,
then I have the power back,
which is exciting.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT:
It's amazing.
I feel like if I took a poll
right now of the audience,
how many of you are just
obsessed with this woman's
voice in general, right?
Exactly, I think your
voice, not to say, defy,
but it does, it defies
like any particular-- yeah,
I know the pun was too easy.
But it really does defy
any particular genre.
I think we're all
obsessed with your voice
and what you're
bringing as an artist.
So I think in that
way, this is--
IDINA MENZEL: Well, I've
been working with a voice
teacher for over 20 years.
She's not the kind of
teacher that you would think.
Before her, when I was
younger, I studied classically.
But then when I started listing
to all of the other music,
I thought, well, I
don't want to sound
like that, like a
lot of people sound
when they've been overly
trained and then they
try to sing soulful
music or whatever.
Her technique is
actually the untraining.
She prepares me how
to breathe and keep
my voice so I can do eight
shows a week and not hurt myself
and I can build my range
and all that stuff.
So we definitely have a
regiment that I can explain,
if anybody's interested in that.
But the point being
it's about singing
from a place of speaking as
opposed to (FANCY SINGING).
That doesn't sound like
any of us talk, right?
So nothing against
that kind of singing.
But what I gravitate to
is coming from speaking,
even if it's the way I would
yell to you on the playground
if I was a kid, that's just
my higher part of my voice.
But it all comes from
how we would communicates
as humans, our real voice.
And I believe that
that's what makes
gives an audience a real
connection to somebody's
because they're really
talking and not performing,
over-producing this sound.
So I don't know why
I told you that.
I forget what you said.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT: No,
that's perfect because we're
just having a conversation.
So here we are.
IDINA MENZEL: So sorry.
I keep drinking the coffee.
It's not really helping.
Maybe it is helping, and I'm
just like, blah, blah, blah,
blah.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT:
No, it's amazing.
I think everybody's
enrapt, like sort
of just shaking their head
in agreement with you--
that relatability.
And like you were saying
earlier, this sort of artifice
between you and the audience
has disappeared in so many ways,
that that connection of what
you're talking about, really
singing in a way that's
accessible to human speaking--
IDINA MENZEL: Yeah, the only
thing working against that
is that we all listen
to music that's
been fixed and auto-tuned
so much, that now
what is perfect and
imperfect can be debated.
And when you go
to a live concert,
are you really
hearing people or not?
And so when you
actually hear someone
that chooses to actually sing,
even when she has a bad cold
or it's that time of month
or she was up at 3:00
in the morning with her son
or fighting with her boyfriend
and I don't sound
perfect, it's taken some
of the love out of it for me.
The social media
takes a lot out of it
because I read it,
like an asshole.
And you know that people
can just go on there
and immediately talk
about everything.
And so it's made it
harder to enjoy it.
I have to really kind of
like turn it off and find
the love of singing,
and also remember
that there have been many shows
where I've sung and not been
at the top of my game, and
people still are in tears
or still feel something.
And I remember, oh,
it's not because I
hit a really high note that
makes someone feel something.
It's because what you're
communicating as a person.
So I have to remember that.
But my whole life has been
about-- my entire identity
has been based on the fact
that when I was a young girl,
I had this voice.
And so as I've
gotten older, I've
had to understand that I have
a lot more to offer the world
than just being a singer.
But sometimes I forget myself.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT:
Well, it also
comes from even
the earlier days.
You were saying you
were sort of taught
to think about
songwriting very early on,
which I would imagine has
actually helped in terms
of thinking beyond just where
the pigeon holes might be
with people thinking about you.
And with that, were
there any, for you,
defining moments in your career,
either joyous or really tough?
I know we talked a
bit about "Rent."
But has there been any
other moments for use
that just really stand out as
an artist, or maybe in a moment
there you suddenly
felt like you had
defied maybe one of those boxes
that somebody had maybe put you
in?
IDINA MENZEL: Yeah, well,
the success of "Let It
Go" and "Frozen" because you
said like with "Rent," that it
was this rock-pop musical.
And you would think that then
that would open doors for me
to be able to walk between
all of these lines.
But it wasn't.
Whenever I'd go into a recording
studio with a big-time producer
or a songwriter, they'd
sort of admonish me
and say like, oh,
you're too expressive.
It's all that Broadway training.
Or you have to sound
more like Sheryl Crow.
Throw it away.
So, I'm sorry.
I lost my train of thought.
So then-- help me.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT:
Defining moments,
where you sort of broke the box.
IDINA MENZEL: Oh, yeah.
And so they would have
all of these rules,
like theater people
are never going
to get on the radio
on a pop station.
And then all of a sudden, cut
to like 15 years later, I'm
taking my kid to
school and Z100's on,
and I hear "Let It Go."
I'm like, what the hell?
You can't worry
about those rules.
And I did for a long time.
You've just got to keep
moving and going and taking
work that makes you feel good.
And surround yourself with
people that teach you stuff,
and just keep going.
Because the trends
and the rules,
they always break
and move and change.
And all of a sudden,
you hear like a bridge.
Like, what's a bridge
in "Let It Go?"
It's like a, "frozen
fractals all around."
There's like these
crazy lyrics that
would never be in a pop song.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT:
The word "fractals?"
IDINA MENZEL: Yeah.
Who rhymes with fractals?
Not me.
I didn't write it.
But you know?
But it's become like this
huge pop culture moment.
So go figure and fuck all those
people that like wrote me off.
So that was a big defining
moment, a teaching moment
for me, just to know you just
can't keep following a trend.
Because by the time you get
there, it's changed already.
So just keep doing your thing.
This album's a big
deal just because I
was with my ex-husband for--
we were married a long time,
but together even
longer, so like 16 years
and grew up together.
So to figure out how
to separate yourself,
who you are separate
from that person
and to be creative without
worrying about what he would
think was interesting and
liberating, too, to just get
in the studio and
go and not worry--
and figuring out how to stop
regretting all of that stuff
and pave the way for some
new exciting stuff to happen.
I got engaged recently.
[APPLAUSE]
JULIE ANN CROMMETT:
Congratulations.
IDINA MENZEL: Thanks.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT: With
that, just thinking even
about "Let It Go"
and the new album
and where they came
from, the journey,
I think, at least
from what I've seen,
and I work a lot on inclusion
issues and representation
issues as part of my day job.
IDINA MENZEL: I was just
in the bathroom stall,
and there's a thing
about inclusion
as I was sitting on the toilet.
You put a thing in front
of me about inclusion.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT:
Learning on the Loo.
IDINA MENZEL: Learning
on Loo, OK, got it.
Well, I was reading it.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT:
It was effective.
If somebody's in here
who did that-- fantastic.
[INAUDIBLE] at Google.
And the fun part
about that is we
work with a lot of
artists who are viewed
as role models in the industry.
And as our friend Gina Davis
says, if you can see it,
you can be it.
And given "Frozen," you brought
up "Frozen" and "Let It Go,"
and now actually, sort
of defining yourself
entirely in this way with the
album in this new moment, who
was a role model in your life?
And have you felt that
that idea of a role model
fall on you now, given how
many little girls and boys kind
of latched on to your music, who
may have not known you before?
What's that been like,
and can you trace it
to somebody in your own life?
IDINA MENZEL: Yeah, well,
first of all, my sister's
a huge role model for me.
She's my younger sister-- 3
and 1/2 years younger than me.
But she got married
and had kids before me,
so our roles reversed
in a lot of ways.
I'd go to her for the
wisdom of certain things.
And she got remarried, so she
went through a bunch of crap
and handled it so gracefully.
She was single and had these two
little tiny boys at the time.
And because she grew up with a
sister, that was always like,
I know what I'm
doing with my life.
I'm singing, I
want to be famous.
And she was like, I
have no idea what to do,
and I have this
annoying sister's shadow
to walk around in.
It took her longer
to figure out what
she wanted to do with her life.
And then she did.
She's this amazing
teacher and a writer.
She's writing a
book, but she did it.
She went back to school
and got her masters
with the two little kids.
And so anyway, just
her strength and grace,
really, has been an
inspiration to me.
She's super, super
smart and eloquent.
The role model thing with
me and the characters
I played, and they're always
connecting to young audiences
is a beautiful thing, and it's
also a daunting responsibility.
One, is that the
age disparity is
getting even bigger and bigger.
So now, like the "Frozen" thing,
there's like six-year-olds,
and then there's me coming.
So like I do a concert.
I'm on stage, talking
like a truck driver.
And then I look down,
and there's just
like mom with a little girl in
a blue dress in front of me.
And I'm talking about how
so and so went up my shirt.
And then I realize, oh, fuck.
And then I do that.
And then it's like, it's
just a constant mess.
And the manager's like, could
you please watch your mouth.
There are these young kids.
I'm like, I've got to be me.
And so it's hard.
Also, there's that.
But then there's also the
part of just all these
amazing characters
I've gotten to play
about young women
finding themselves,
embracing this
thing in them that's
super unique and beautiful,
but sort of looked down
upon by society.
And then they finally
harness it, embrace it,
and do amazing things with it.
That whole idea is great.
But it's not always who I am.
So I specifically put "Creep"
by Radiohead in my set
last year when I was on tour
because it was an opportunity
to just sing a song about
feeling completely despicable
and letting them know that I
don't always feel letting it go
or "Defying Gravity."
It's not easy to wake up every
day and sing songs like that,
and you shouldn't have to.
Sometimes you just want to
feel really sorry for yourself
and stay in bed,
and that's OK too.
That's how I've been
grappling with it.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT:
That's awesome.
I just had this
vision of you in bed,
and the Creed song
playing life over.
And it's so real.
I think this is a truth,
by the way, with everybody
we've talked to in that space,
is this sort of pressure to be
on for especially
the little kids
and how to balance that
with being a real human.
And that maybe showing them
that you're a real human
is actually even a
more impactful thing.
And with that, in
that vein, just doing
a little bit of research
on you before this,
there was some
exciting real work
that you've done with kids
and also in the philanthropy
and activism space,
which I didn't
want us to go
without talking about
because it's so important.
Weird factoid-- my high school
was the first high school
outside the city of New York to
support Broadway Cares Equity
Fights Aids in
Marietta, Georgia, where
LGBTQ rights were not
very welcome at the time
that we started
collecting donations.
And so I was particularly moved
by your activism in that space.
So thank you.
And would love if you'd like
to talk a little bit about what
you've done and what
you've been working on,
maybe what's to
come in that space.
IDINA MENZEL: Well, I was
lucky enough as a kid.
My parents would send me
away to sleepaway camp.
It's a Jewish East
Coast thing to do.
And it was a privileged thing.
But it was a wonderful
experience, an opportunity
to escape, to kind of
rewrite yourself as a kid
if you didn't enjoy
your school year.
It's a place to bond
and make new friends
and find yourself, really.
And I always wanted
to have a camp.
And then as I got
older and I started
to have these experiences
and these projects where
it was connecting to
young women, especially,
young women trying
to find their voice,
I realized that the camp
had to be more than just
what I experienced
when I was younger
and be more
meaningful than that.
And so my college roommate,
who's much smarter than me,
and was sick and
tired of hearing me
talk about this pipe dream.
And so she galvanized
the whole thing.
She's a business major,
lawyer, type-A person,
got the thing together.
And it's called The Broader Way.
And we're going on
our seventh year.
It's a 10-day
program, where we take
a bunch of inner-city
girls, mostly
from Harlem and the
Lower East Side,
up to the Berkshire Mountains
in Massachusetts for 10 days
to like a college campus that
we lease the property for now.
Eventually, hopefully,
we'll have our own place.
And we sing, and we
dance, and we swam.
And Jeanine Tesori, who's an
incredible Broadway composer,
wrote "Fun Home"
and a ton of things.
She's kind of like
my creative director.
And we bring up amazing
veteran performers
that come and work with them.
But the whole thing is not
to put on like "Oklahoma"
with these girls.
We encourage them
to write a lot.
They do a lot of spoken word.
They write their
own songs, lyrics.
They choreograph
their own movement.
And so at the end
of the 10 days,
they come back into New York
to a theater that's usually,
thankfully, given
to us for the night.
And we put on a recital,
concert, if you will,
that's a complete collage
of their original work.
So it's-- and so we started
with 30 girls the first year.
And now it's become
a four-year program.
And we're now at the point
where our original girls
came back and were
CITs, only the ones
that we thought were
capable of doing that,
because they still are only 15.
Yeah, and so now we're up to
like 80 girls or something.
And that's a huge
responsibility.
And it's hard-- all the fund
raising and all that stuff
and also wanting to keep tabs
on them through the year.
Because I always
find, even as adults,
when we're involved in
a really amazing project
and then we're finished,
we kind of crash.
And so I imagine
these girls, who
have these kind of shitty
home life, a lot of them.
And they go from this magical
10 days, and then they go back.
And so I want to make sure
they felt like it wasn't over.
And through the year,
we do little reunions.
And they go see shows
together, and we
go see art and tap dance.
We have like dance
things and whatever.
Anyway, so it's a constantly
evolving foundation.
We want to get to
the point where
we have college funds for
them and things like that.
But that's all in the future.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT:
That's amazing.
IDINA MENZEL: Thanks.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT:
That's really awesome.
IDINA MENZEL: Thanks.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT:
And it just gets
me thinking also about sort of
this journey you were talking
about earlier about
role modeling,
because in a way, that's a
place where you're becoming very
human to them and them to you.
And I think that's really
awesome and remarkable.
And with that, I want
to do two more questions
I'd be remiss if not asking.
I would like to do some word
association before we turn it
over to the audience.
This should be fun, everybody,
especially given the coffee.
IDINA MENZEL:
--that I'm so tired.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT: Yeah-- chug.
[LAUGHTER]
And also, I had
one more in here.
Before you do that,
what's the one thing--
we do work at Google.
What's the one thing that
we couldn't Google search
about you?
IDINA MENZEL: So
there's a lot out there.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT: I know.
I know.
IDINA MENZEL: I don't know.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT:
Or you'd like
us to know that you wouldn't
normally talk about.
IDINA MENZEL: Because, as
you see, I'm a open book.
So it's like I don't
hide that much.
But I'm pretty much
a slob at home.
I'm not dirty.
There's a difference
between dirty and messy.
I don't like oatmeal like
left out for ants to eat.
I don't like that.
I like the counter to be clean.
But like my clothes
are everywhere.
The bathroom's a mess--
the towels, the things.
The bed's hardly ever made
unless people are coming over
and I want to pretend
that it's clean.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT: I
love that, by the way.
I also a messy and dirty.
There is a distinctive
difference.
IDINA MENZEL:
There's a difference.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT: Yeah.
IDINA MENZEL: We
shower all the time.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT:
Yeah, thank god.
IDINA MENZEL: My hair's clean.
I just don't like
putting things away.
I'm not very organized.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT: If you
take anything away from here,
we both showered today.
IDINA MENZEL: Yes, we did.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT: But
we don't make the bed.
IDINA MENZEL: Exactly.
I showered last night
and this morning.
I brushed my teeth even, which
is a lot for a mother, who,
by the way, got up.
My son slept at
dad's last night,
but he couldn't take him
to school this morning.
And I didn't want
the nanny to do
that because I had enough time.
So I got up, made his
lunches, because dad never
makes his good lunches.
I do.
And then drove over there, which
is 10 minutes away, completely
in my pajamas, didn't brush
my teeth, rolled out of bed.
Yet, I did it on Friday,
and the paparazzi
got a picture of me doing
that, which was really nice.
I was dropping him off at dad's.
And they said I was going to
daycare for dropping him off
at daycare, and it was
actually his house.
It was Taye's house.
It was like get
your facts straight,
But anyway, what was I saying?
So I was just a
mess this morning.
The lunch is the thing.
Got him to school
10 minutes late.
Every mom at the school
is like perfectly coiffed
with like three kids and a job.
I don't know.
Me and like Amy Poehler,
we both go to this school.
And she's the only
one I know, like I
can tell she rolled
out of bed in her PJs
and got the kid to school like
within a second of being late.
And I'm like, thank god, for
Amy, because these other moms
are so annoying.
[LAUGHTER]
JULIE ANN CROMMETT:
Respect-- respect that.
I see some heads nodding
in the room, yes?
We all love that.
We've been there.
Right on.
I see some hands.
IDINA MENZEL: Yeah, you've got
to sleep in like cool sweat
pants that with like a
cool rock-and-roll boot
looks like you meant
it, but you just slept,
and you wear the PJs to school.
Put on the cool boot,
and it's like you
meant it to happen that way.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT:
These are pro tips.
IDINA MENZEL: Yes.
And I only have one kid.
Some of these moms have three.
So I don't know-- and they're
skinny, you know what I mean?
JULIE ANN CROMMETT:
That's LA, man.
That's LA.
We can't explain it.
IDINA MENZEL:
Can't explain that.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT:
I'm telling you.
And then you get to New
York, and all you want to do
is eat a bagel.
I'm like, can we please?
IDINA MENZEL: I know.
That's like the
minute I get there,
I have to order from this deli.
I still know the phone number
by heart-- (212)993-3373.
It's Bagel On The Corner Deli.
It's crazy.
I have to have a bagel with
cream cheese, a black and white
cookie.
It's like going to the movies
and you have to have popcorn.
As soon as I get to New
York, that's what I have.
Anyway, I'm sorry.
This isn't interesting.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT:
I respect that.
No.
Did we all write
down that number?
I feel like that was a really
good bagel rec for all of us
here.
We have a huge New York office.
So this is actually great.
And so with that, before we
turn it over to the honest,
I'm sure there's a lot of
burning questions, a quick word
association.
One word-- first one
that pops in your mind.
Are you ready?
IDINA MENZEL: No.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT: Progress?
IDINA MENZEL: Oh, I'm
going to be honest?
JULIE ANN CROMMETT:
Yeah, be honest.
IDINA MENZEL: The name
of my boyfriend/fiance--
I hate that word.
His name's Aaron.
Progress-- I don't
know why he popped in.
I think because he's-- yeah,
because I think he makes me
a better person.
He used to be an actor.
But now he's this amazing
addiction specialist
and has his master's
in psychology
and works in this rehab.
And he's a Neanderthal,
but he communicates well.
And he's just-- I feel like I'm
my best self when I'm with him.
So I hate that I made it
about a man, but I did.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT: Here we
are, progress [INAUDIBLE].
We'll try another one-- music.
IDINA MENZEL: Walker came
into my mind, my son, Walker,
because I finally-- he
hates Mommy singing.
He hates "Frozen."
He hates it all.
But I got him to sit down
at the piano with me.
I just shipped my piano from
New York to my new house in LA.
And I got him to sit with me.
You can't tell my
son to do something.
He has find it on his own.
Otherwise, he's
like-- but we started
writing a little song
on the piano together.
And we titled it, and it was
called-- what was it called?
"The Fire House" or something.
I don't know.
Anyway, it was a lot
of scary bass notes
because he's into
zombies and werewolves.
But that was music
to me, because I've
been waiting to have a
moment where I could somehow
inspire him with my musicality.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT: I love that.
Theater?
IDINA MENZEL: Home.
Theater is home to me.
No matter what has happened
in my career, ups and downs,
I always can go back.
And I end up falling
into a wonderful show.
Whether it's hugely
successful or not,
I have this experience
with a cast and community.
Recording music is sort of more
of more solitary experience.
And theater is family,
so, yeah, home.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT: And time?
IDINA MENZEL: Time-- T-I-M-E?
JULIE ANN CROMMETT: Yeah, time.
IDINA MENZEL: (SIGHING)
Time-- I'm blanking.
Time-- time for me is age maybe.
Yeah, the man wants
me to have a baby,
and I'm like, just
forget it, man.
So it's time.
Like is there enough time?
And if there is, do I even
want to do that with this time?
Or do I want to travel
and have a life now?
So it's kind of about
the clock ticking time.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT: I love it.
One last one-- joy.
IDINA MENZEL: Joy?
JULIE ANN CROMMETT: Yeah.
IDINA MENZEL: Yeah,
joy is jumping on
the-- it's the trampoline that
I built at my house-- jumping
both boys, total
release of energy,
just jumping on a trampoline.
It's like so much fun.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT: I love it.
And with that, I'd love to
turn it over to the audience.
We have some mics in the middle.
Anybody want to come
up and ask a question?
Oh, we already have one.
Excellent.
IDINA MENZEL: It's
funny you have the mics.
You probably can just ask me.
I probably don't even need this.
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
My name is Shannon.
First of all, I just want
to make a comment before.
Thank you for coming out.
And I just want to
tell you that I grew up
like just so looking up to you.
I lived in Arizona.
And I'm sure we
all listened to you
and maybe didn't get
to see you on Broadway.
And it was so cool because
you came here to the Greek.
It was your first time,
I think, performing.
And I came and saw you.
And it was awesome
because you were so real.
I loved even just the
times in between the music
more than like your
actual singing.
So it's cool to see
you, to be honest.
IDINA MENZEL: I appreciate that.
AUDIENCE: So I just say,
like I'm sure, in case
you don't hear it
enough, because you
said about the social
and I'm sure there
are people saying good and bad.
But like keep being like
you and authentic and real
because like people
do respect that.
IDINA MENZEL: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Now I'll
get to my question.
So I'm always fascinated by like
how people prepare for roles.
And so I'd love to hear about
when you prepared how was it
like preparing for like Maureen
an Elphaba and that time
in your life versus
preparing for like Liz, which
was like you're kind of
come back to New York,
and maybe that character
reflected more of like you?
Or I don't know.
I'm just maybe guessing.
And then how you prepare
for like your album,
like how does it like juxtapose
the preparation for a character
versus like--
IDINA MENZEL: Well, there's
technical preparation,
which if it involves
music, then there's
like the singing
aspect, literally
the athleticism of
what that entails
and preparing that, which means
the teacher I told you about.
It means like treating
myself, like if you were going
to run the marathon,
you wouldn't go run
26 miles out of nowhere, right?
You'd build up.
So I do all of this preparation.
I meet with her.
We go through all the music.
We pick all the things.
Like, oh, that's going
to be hard on a matinee.
And like I start singing
a certain amount of time.
I literally little time myself--
15 minutes a day for a week.
And then I start to move it up.
And all of a sudden,
my voice gets bigger,
and the range gets bigger.
And so I treat that
like an athlete.
And then as far
as characters go,
it's changed because
I feel like I
have more of a technique and a
process as I've gotten older.
When I was younger, I
used to kind of just
throw it out there.
But how do I prepare?
It's more to me
about the words, less
about worrying about how does
it feel to wear green makeup.
I mean, I went and
watched "The Wizard of Oz"
and like watched
Margaret Hamilton.
But that was just to kind of get
some cool ideas to play off of
and a fun cackle and
her laugh, whatever.
But for the most part, it's
about the language, the words,
knowing them in such a way that
it's like song in a way, to me.
It's like jazz, so I can just
be in the moment and riff off
of that.
Yeah, it's about knowing that
so well, that you can just
be open and receive.
So I'm not giving a good
explanation of that.
AUDIENCE: No that
was good, yeah.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT: I
think that was great.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
IDINA MENZEL: Thank you.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT: Yes?
AUDIENCE: So when you are in
the middle of a run on Broadway
or something, what is
your daily routine like?
What's it really like?
Are you one of those
people that rolls out
of bed at noon and then--
IDINA MENZEL: I was.
AUDIENCE: Because
you work late, right?
IDINA MENZEL: Yeah, that's
what's so hard about it.
AUDIENCE: What is
that day really like?
I'd like to get a picture?
IDINA MENZEL: OK,
well, there's pre-baby,
and then there's post-baby.
AUDIENCE: Well, also,
secondarily, I'm
sure it was
different now than it
was when you were doing "Rent."
IDINA MENZEL: Yeah.
No, it's sleep, sleep, sleep is
the best feeling for a voice,
first of all-- so as much
they pursue possible always.
But sometimes you can't.
And if you're nervous, you
don't sleep well either
like the night before.
But when you're in like
a routine, I come home.
I watch a movie.
I'm wound up.
So I get home, and I'm
up late because I still
can't go to sleep.
I just did a performance.
So that adrenaline
is still wearing off.
So then, yeah, sleep in,
I steam all the time.
I'm like a big steamer.
So I will sit like in a shower.
I'm not good for California.
I waste a lot of water.
But I like steam.
I vocalize and then make
my way over to the theater.
But with the child,
it's just changed it.
Because all of a sudden,
I couldn't get the sleep.
Everything was just
thrown up in upheaval.
I feel like I end up enjoying
myself more on stage now
that I have a child because I'm
like, well, I can't be perfect.
So what can I do?
He had a fever, and I'm
trying to be a good mom.
So I get up there.
And then I end up doing
better because I'm
more relaxed, because I just
throw caution to the wind.
As opposed to like I
warmed up for 25 minutes,
and I didn't drink any wine, and
I didn't smoke any cigarettes,
and I'm perfect, perfect,
perfect, and then
I still miss the
note-- oh, my, god.
So now I'm more of a human
being, and I enjoy myself more.
AUDIENCE: That's great.
Thank you.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT:
Another one, yes.
AUDIENCE: First off,
congratulations on your album.
As another parent, I really
enjoyed the sentiment
in "Perfect Story."
Now more of a story of
myself, because after I
heard you singing "Defying
Gravity" in "Wicked,"
it inspired me to
start singing lessons.
Because I have no theater
background or singing
background.
I'm a total geek.
But I started taking private
lessons a couple years.
I even started a
chorus here at work.
And some of the
members are here.
And just I've always
wanted to sing,
but I've never felt as
inspired as I did when I heard
you sing "Defying Gravity."
And I just wanted to be able
to sing along with that.
And my singing
instructor has also
started off trying
to teach me how
to sing kind of like
you, the whole belt
by shouting, which
is a lot like--
IDINA MENZEL: Healthy shouting.
AUDIENCE: Exactly, without
destroying my throat.
IDINA MENZEL: Well, because like
children scream all the time
and they never walk
around with laryngitis.
So they do it in a
way that's very free.
So that's the thought
process, not like screaming.
It's that idea that you
call across the playground
to your friend.
You're like, hey, Johnny.
And then you're like, hey!
It's the same thing.
That's how I think of it.
And I would listen to Chaka
Kahn and Aretha Franklin
and actually mimic
them all the time
to figure out how
are they doing that.
And so the best way to learn
I think is to emulate people.
And then because we're who
we are, it'll never be them.
It will still be
unique and true to us.
So anyway, I cut you off.
AUDIENCE: No, not at all.
I just want to let you know how
your singing has touched me.
IDINA MENZEL: Oh, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
IDINA MENZEL: Thank you so much.
So what are you
singing in the choir?
What kind of music?
AUDIENCE: We kind
of sing everything.
We sing "Summertime."
We sing Disney music.
IDINA MENZEL: Oh, fun.
That's great I actually
miss being in a choir.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT:
Well, maybe, if you
would like to sing in a choir,
I'm just connecting dots here,
as the moderator.
It feels like
opportunities abound.
IDINA MENZEL: I'm
very out of practice,
though, with the four-part
harmony and everything.
It's coed.
It's obviously--
JULIE ANN CROMMETT:
It's very cool.
AUDIENCE: So I have something
I've been wondering ever
since I saw "Enchanted."
And at this point,
you had very well
established yourself, both
in terms of your acting
and singing prowess.
So it surprises me seeing
you in a musical movie role
without a song in
the whole movie.
So do you have any thoughts on--
IDINA MENZEL: Well, it wasn't
written as a singing part.
And so I actually
was so flattered
because I was like I know.
I'm an actress.
I'm not just a singer.
So I was happy and
relieved to not
have to worry about singing.
Because a lot of
times it's a relief
not to sing or to worry
about having it all there.
So I was happy about that.
But once I was in it,
they wrote something.
And then it end up just being
superfluous because they
were trying too hard.
They wrote a whole song
for me and the prince
at the end, James
Marsden, and it got cut.
He knew it too.
I was so excited.
And he's like, this
is totally ending up
on the cutting room floor.
I was like, no, it's not.
It's awesome.
He's like, there's no reason for
this song to be in this movie.
They're going to totally cut it.
But thank you for
thinking of that.
But I was actually happy.
And then I got to take--
my first day of rehearsal
in that movie, I had to
show up at a dance studio--
a ballroom dance studio-- and
dance with Patrick Dempsey
and James Marsden this close and
learned-- and I'm not a dancer.
People think is I'm from
Broadway I can dance.
I cannot.
I have to have a special
session with the choreographer
to teach me eight counts.
That's like how bad
I am, but imagine
having a go at those two hot
guys and like stand this close
and try to be-- it
was heaven and it
was hell at the same time.
AUDIENCE: Well, thank you
for satisfying my curiosity.
[LAUGHTER]
JULIE ANN CROMMETT: I
think everybody just
had this wonderful vision in
their heads of those two men
at it exactly the same time.
IDINA MENZEL: Oh, my god.
And you have to have your butt--
it's like "Dirty Dancing."
This is my dance space.
This is your dance space.
He's going to like
touch my arm, like that.
You know how when Patrick
Swayze does that thing.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT:
It's so nice.
IDINA MENZEL: And she's
like tickled by it.
That's how I felt.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT: Let's
all just take a moment
and take that in for a second.
IDINA MENZEL: You know what
I'm talking about, right?
In the movie?
OK.
[LAUGHTER]
JULIE ANN CROMMETT: Oh, yeah.
Oh yeah, we got an
enthusiastic oh, yeah.
Any other questions?
We have time for one
or two more, anybody?
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm Tom.
So I was wondering, do
you have a favorite song?
And how often does your
favorite song change?
IDINA MENZEL: Yeah, I don't
because it does change,
depending on how I feel.
I can tell you that
the things people would
think I get sick, like "Let
It Go" or "Defying Gravity,"
I don't get sick
of singing them.
Maybe it's the
creature of theater
that I am, where you
are always looking
for something new, just
the tiniest thing from show
to show to keep it fresh.
So that's an exercise
that I enjoy.
So either it's a little
girl in the front row
and I like, oh, I'm going to
sing "Let It Go" to her today.
She never saw a concert.
Or I think it to my son,
or I think of a new melody
because I'm sick and
I have to come up
with something different cause
I can't hit the high note.
So then I'm like,
oh, that was cool.
Whatever it is, I give
myself those exercises.
So that can be fun.
But it changes, depending
on the day, really.
That's the cool
thing about music
is like what you bring to it.
The song kind of
unfolds differently.
I used to sing "Both
Sides Now," Joni Mitchell,
and that was a great song
that would sort of just reveal
itself to me differently every
time I sang it, depending
on what perspective I had.
So that was nice.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT: We hosted
you in the Joni Mitchell Room,
without even knowing this.
IDINA MENZEL: Oh, yeah?
Is she here?
JULIE ANN CROMMETT: That
is the conference room
that we were in.
IDINA MENZEL: Oh.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT: It
was all Joni Mitchell.
IDINA MENZEL: Really?
JULIE ANN CROMMETT: Yeah,
look at that, everybody.
I know we have to
wrap up because people
have to get to
their next meetings,
unfortunately, in the
workday, although I'm
sure everybody would
like to stay here
for another hour, yeah.
If you could think of
one piece of advice
that you received that you'd
want to share with all of us
today, what's the thing
that always sticks out
in your mind-- piece of advice?
IDINA MENZEL: Is it
helpful in this arena?
I guess it could
be in life's arena.
Yeah, it's just, I
feel like nobody's
looking for a copy or a
clone of somebody else.
So as much as we want
to be like other people
and admire other
people, the more we
figure out what makes
us completely unique,
that will be the most desired
thing, whether it's in the arts
or it's in business.
So when you find that
thing that sets you apart,
that's the thing that's
going to make you
more desirable and successful.
So like when we're
younger, we think
we should be like other people.
And it's not till we
realize that if we're
as authentic as we can
possibly be, that eventually
that you will reveal
yourself to the world.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT:
That's awesome.
Thank you for that.
And thank you for being here.
IDINA MENZEL: Thank you, guys.
I think they gave you
CDs and everything.
And also, like I think I'm
on Google Play or something
like that.
JULIE ANN CROMMETT:
I believe you are.
In fact, download
it on Google Play.
Everybody, please join me in
thanking Idina for joining us.
IDINA MENZEL: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]